[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
monday morning
happy
happy monday morning
to all of you out there who are not in a
deaf cult
or a cult in general really
i mean amy coney barrett apparently was
in and is and promotes cults uh 44 of
republicans are in a death cult ah
there's nothing we can do about school
shootings this is just a thing that's
gonna happen
it's just we got gun boners
and we have to have school shootings to
appease our gun boners don't you know
this
[Laughter]
no [ __ ] well that's just the way it is
folks i mean i don't know how much i put
stock in these polls that 44 percent of
republicans just believe that
gun violence and schools and school
shootings are just the thing we have to
put up with in this country
but is it really that hard to believe
and when you really get down and start
thinking about it these [ __ ] people
are in a death cult
they [ __ ] they they want guns in schools
i mean the manufacturers are excited
about having school shootings
it means more sales
means more sales especially if these
republicans are like oh these this is
just inevitable we need to give the
teachers the janitors the principals and
the students guns just give everyone
guns in that building and then lock it
lock the building with all the guns
inside that'd be perfect
the gun manufacturers are [ __ ]
excited about this
absolutely this means more sales
miniature
miniature ar 415s maybe they're ar 8s
you know since they're eight years old
jesus [ __ ] christ
really is
uh boneheaded [ __ ] boneheaded there's
no other way to describe it that 44
percent of republicans think that school
shootings are just inevitable that's
just a thing that happens
that's where we are that's where we are
now if you really look at it how many
people in this country still identify as
republican i mean you know it might have
been at one point in this country you
know 45 45
and then you know maybe even 40 40 and
then
20
were independents or moderates right i
don't know what the actual makeup is and
it changes from [ __ ] insurrection to
insurrection i'm sure
but think about this how many people
actually identify as republican anymore
would you identify as republican are you
[ __ ] kidding me
jesus christ
matt walsh can't even tell you what a
woman is he made a whole movie what's a
woman
he has no idea he's never seen a woman
never met a woman
probably never been able to
actually carry on a conversation with a
woman for more than five or ten minutes
matt walsh you [ __ ] piece he wouldn't
know what a goddamn woman was if she sat
on his [ __ ] face
matt walsh you insult piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] running around asking people if
they know what a woman is listen when
someone asks you this question it's
really [ __ ] simple these [ __ ]
death cult members these matt walsh
tucker carlson gun manufacturing ted
cruz
greg abbott marjorie taylor green lauren
bobert types these [ __ ]
when they ask you what a woman is
when they ask you this this is a really
[ __ ] dumb question in the first place
there's [ __ ] definitions you [ __ ]
idiot
when someone asks you
what's a woman you lib [ __ ] you say
here's what you say it is a gender that
somebody identifies as
that's that's what you say that's what
you said you look at them and then you
say you follow it up with a question of
course and then you say do you identify
as a woman
and they'll say no
or they'll say yes one one of the other
i mean it's kind of a yes or no question
i mean there's there can be some
ambiguity there
but yes or no
and then you say well i'm glad you agree
that it's something that someone
identifies that you [ __ ] boneheads
you you people are [ __ ] dumb that you
think you think
just because someone has a certain
genitalia tell you that they can't
identify as a woman you people are
[ __ ] stupid
matt walsh you dumb [ __ ] again
he wouldn't know a goddamn woman
if she came over and sat on his [ __ ]
face
no [ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way would he know what a
woman is this is why he's running that's
why he had to make a whole movie a whole
movie of what a woman is he doesn't know
they don't know his in cell his incel
crowd the people who who sent for him
have no [ __ ] clue what a woman is
that's why he had to make a whole movie
to explain it to these [ __ ]
knuckleheads
these [ __ ] in-cell white dudes
sitting in their mom's basement
ridiculous
but 44 percent of republicans it's the
same [ __ ] by the way
the same [ __ ] this venn diagram
is a goddamn circle it's a [ __ ]
circle the same [ __ ] that
believe that there's nothing we can do
about school shootings
are the same stupid bastards running
around asking people if they know what a
woman is
same [ __ ]
there's no difference
it's the exact same
the same people that are like oh elon
musk is going to own twitter he's going
to own twitter there's no way he can he
can not oh he's going to fix it too
freedom of speech he's going to get rid
of the bots it's going to be fantastic
all the whole world's going to be fixed
because elon musk owns twitter
really
elon musk is going to own twitter is he
give me a [ __ ] break
never never in a million years was that
[ __ ] gonna buy twitter not in a
million [ __ ] years he is now using
the excuse
that he used to buy twitter to get out
of twitter deal i'm gonna buy twitter
and get rid of the box that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna get rid of the bots
he he has a bot farm
13 million 13 million of elon musk
followers
are fake accounts
fake they're [ __ ] fake
13 million he has his own bot farm a 13
million accounts
and he's pissed off about
twitter having bots and he was like i'm
going to fix this problem we're going to
get rid of the bots and it's going to be
a place where you can say and type in
almost anything you want and push tweet
that's what it is now you dumb
[ __ ]
i type in all kinds of crazy [ __ ] into
twitter and push tweet
still there
still free to speak hell i'm
broadcasting this live right now on
twitter
now [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ] no
no there's no freedom of speech i mean
there's terms in certain terms of
service
you have to follow the terms of service
that there's that thing
but elon musk now is gonna back out of
the twitter deal he's gonna back out
because there's spots
oh boy oh boy
if you guys noticed this morning um i
don't know what happened when i tried to
actually post this show on uh at tony
michael's pod
it did not it did not post for whatever
reason the service is not connecting so
i had to post it from my personal
twitter account but it's still on
twitter we're still on twitter i don't
know maybe elon knew
that i was going to be talking about him
and he secretly owns twitter and we just
don't know it yet because all his stands
have helped him find it i don't know
you know if he really had this many
people that loved him you think they'd
pitch in a few dollars right i pitch in
a few [ __ ] dollars
and then and then when they pitch in a
few bucks he could now go by twitter
right if he has so many [ __ ]
followers so many people that love him
get the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
elon musk is not never going to own
twitter i mean he may own stock
he's not gonna own twitter give me a
[ __ ] break
i'm excited to have you guys here this
morning
you guys you know every single weekday
every single weekday we broadcast live
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter and twitch and we
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page
over there on the facebook page there's
a link to our youtube channel if you
want to subscribe there go ahead and
click that link
and get over and subscribe
to the tony michaels podcast over on
youtube
we have some special special things
coming up this week and i want to talk
about it for a second this is going to
be
a huge event you guys know the january 6
select committee is going to have their
public hearings the schedule is starting
to unfold here
on june 9th which is this thursday
the first prime time
hearing
uh it starts
at eight eastern
eight o'clock p.m eastern what we're
going to do is we're going to broadcast
at 7 o'clock p.m eastern so an hour
before we're gonna have plenty of
commentary
with that the legal af team so michael
popock
karen agnipolo and ben mizellis we're
also going to get commentary from jordy
and brett micellis it looks like we're
going to have a few other personalities
that are going to be coming in and
giving us commentary that night
live during the hearing and we're going
to broadcast
we'll be putting out a link later today
to you might midas touch youtube channel
but we will be broadcasting all the
hearings on the midas touch youtube
channel so make sure to be watching for
that youtube link that is going to be
super important for you to watch
the january 6th select committee public
hearings
uh from here on out rather they do six
or eight it looks like there's going to
be six of them that's kind of what they
got on the schedule and they may add two
more and they kind of keep hinting at
that but it looks like there's going to
be six there's two prime time hearings
the very first one is this thursday
on the ninth
it's going to be get our coverage is
going to begin at 7 00 p.m eastern
and we're going to go until the
hearing's over and then we're going to
have commentary after
so we'll have commentary before
commentary during while they're not
speaking and the proceedings are going
on and then we'll have commentary after
i will be hosting the event and again
it'll be on the midas touch youtube
channel so be looking for that link
today we'll be putting that link out so
everyone can find it everyone can go set
your reminders to make sure you do not
miss
our coverage
of the january 6 select committee
hearings the public hearings
as they start to unfold over the next
three weeks because it is over the next
three weeks there's one this week
there's a few next week and there's a
few the week after
so be paying attention
to those dates we'll be putting out some
graphics we'll be putting out links but
the very first hearing is this thursday
in the evening our coverage will start
at 7 00 pm eastern the hearing starts at
8 pm eastern so be checking that out
make sure you go follow
midas touch on their
on your youtube channel and subscribe
over there
so you are ready to go and you know
exactly where you're going to watch
because boy do we have a lot of new
listeners
holy moly
uh i just want to give some shout outs
here it's monday morning so let's shout
out to some people megan
from youtube christina ann is here
amanda is here debbie from salt lake
cathy's here suzanne's here caitlin's
here ann is here jay is here mj good
morning for us from facebook patricia
from facebook carol nicki mary from
facebook uh who else do we have and from
facebook captain terp is here uh midas
margie is here
uh kinky streets
dark pepsi anita jane from facebook is
here
uh holy moly we just have so many new
listeners lee is here and is here
janie's here
and the 420 god is here
thank you thank you for continuing to
join us
don't forget again if you have not
subscribed to our youtube channel to get
over there and subscribe to them the
tony michaels podcast
youtube channel that is where you can
find all of our videos you can also
download every single episode monday
through friday you know we record it
live but then i put it up on apple
spotify google
for you to download every single weekday
you also have bonus episodes on the
weekends on saturday we have the best of
the week and then every friday every
single friday in the second hour we do
the bonehead of the week poll and we
post that bone hint of the week
on the podcast directories on sundays we
also air it on the youtube channel so
don't forget to go follow the youtube
channel and follow us on twitter at toni
michael's pod at the tony michaels and i
am gabe sanchez this morning i had a
little snafu again with the twitter
account i'm not sure why twitter wasn't
connecting
but the pod account twitter was not
connecting so i broadcast it from my
my personal at the tony michaels so go
follow both
that way if you want to watch it on
twitter you can find it i retweeted it
so it's there somewhere
i'm sure folks are watching this morning
we got a lot of news to go over today
there's a lot of stuff trending
and again we have the defense production
act
is trending now bruce johnson is
trending david hogg marge is trending
conservative
is trending i mean trending downward
they're not conservative get the [ __ ]
out of here with that [ __ ] they've never
been conservative ever
it's all been a ruse that's right it's a
ruse
i said it
so
let's let's do this because we go
through the tweety tweets and eternity
trends and i want to get to we're 18
minutes into the first hour gabe sanchez
will be joining us as he normally does
at the bottom of the hour we'll talk a
little more about the january 6
select hearing but let's do this let's
surf the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast we have reached the
part of the show where we round up all
the tweety tweets and trendy trends in
the [ __ ] list
roundup the shitless roundup holy moly
and do we have a lot of [ __ ] to round up
and there was a lot of stuff over the
weekend
i you know i try to take a break from
twitter
on the weekends i try i try
i try but sometimes it's very very
difficult
because you get things that just pop up
and you got to go look at them and see
them i don't know if you guys have seen
this um there is a group out there
called fire boobert this is the same
group uh they took down madison cawthron
and lauren
their lauren brobert is next on their
list here's a daily beast article about
it um you should go definitely read this
article here about
um fire a bobert it's again it's the
same you remember you remember the
cousin humping video right you remember
the cousin humping video the cousin
humping video oh my god who doesn't
remember that woo
i i really i would not be surprised i
wouldn't would you be surprised if there
is a lauren bobert cousin humping video
i'm sure there's going to be some some
video from a bowling alley possibly i
don't know i have no idea
i have no idea if there is or not
apparently there is a hotline too that
you can call to give a tip on um
on some of the shenanigans because
there's a whole list of shenanigans that
lauren beaubert and her husband have
gotten into over the years oh god
oh god oh god
so go check out fire bobert um again
it's the same group that took down
madison cawthorne
with the uh cousin touch and cousin
humping videos we did it we did our own
version of it here
and then we did a uh a dark maga you
guys should go subscribe to the youtube
channel definitely want to subscribe to
the youtube channel and check out
the parody satire playlist the dark
manga is on there and so is the uh
our version of the cousin humping video
just saying
you might want to go follow over there
uh
mayo tweets here let's see let's pull
this up here mayo says good morning to
everyone who knows that amy coney
barrett is
a batshit crazy cult member so the news
kind of breaks here that any amy coney
barrett is part of a is part of a cult
oh surprise surprise apparently some
court documents
um from years ago reveal that she is a
member of some kind of praise jesus
i'm in a death cult type thing i don't
know i i don't know i don't know
who could tell with these [ __ ]
anymore
it's it's getting ridiculous
it's getting ridiculous
it's it's absurd it's absurd we'll get
to that we'll get to that feed now i
want to go through that with uh with
gabe i know he's got a lot of opinions
on the amy coney beard uh did you guys
see over the over the weekend this was
another thing that happened and we'll
probably watch this video uh kyle
rittenhouse said [ __ ] murderer that's
right kyle i said it murderer sue me
[ __ ]
sue me come on
come on sue me do it send me a cease and
desist you're a [ __ ] murderer you
murdered those people
i mean you got away with it but you
still murdered him you piece of [ __ ]
kyle rittenhouse says i'm going to go to
texas a m right he he announces on
charlie kirk's traitor tv cable tv
station
he announces on charlie kirk show
that he's going to go to texas a m he
even puts the head up we'll watch it
we'll watch it you know i i don't i
don't hold back anything
you gotta you gotta see all this [ __ ]
especially when when kyle rittenhouse
and charlie kirk are gaslighting his
[ __ ] followers and what the funny
part is the funny part is is the reason
why he says he's gonna go to texas a m
because of chicken strips i'm not
[ __ ] you chicken strips
chicken strips is the reason why he says
he's gonna go to texas a m and texas a m
responds to like he's not no
no he's not coming to texas a m he can
go get [ __ ] basically
texas a m told told kyle rittenhouse
where to go and where to stick it
well it's glorious glorious so machine
gun machine pun kelly
um post
here
a texas a m is not that's that's not
that's not real
it's not real i mean they they like to
have a lot of fantasy
they like to have a lot of fantasy
here's another um great story that gabe
posted let's pull this up here
uh over the weekend members of the
failed people's convoy you guys remember
the truckers convoy
we did a couple uh parody videos on that
it appears in the commercial breaks here
every once in a while
but uh zachary
reports here members of the failed
people's convoy now the 1776 restoration
movement see they had to change their
name because the convoy thing didn't
work
yeah [ __ ] what are we gonna do now so
they changed their name you know they
always rebranding at in the in 1920s and
1930s germany they were called nazis
and then they're america first here and
you know then they were the the
republican party then they were the gop
and then they were the tea party and
then they were a maga and then they're a
dark maga they gotta re-brand they gotta
keep rebranding the alt-right you know
they gotta rebrand and rebrand and
rebrand their fascism um the
1776 restoration movement we're told the
locals would donate
a hundred foot long subway sandwich
for their encampment a hundred
that's a big [ __ ] sandwich folks
think about this the the tens of people
that were there you know like the 18 or
19
that were at this people's convoy now
the 1776 nazi movement
um they were they were they were
expecting a hundred foot sandwich can
you imagine
how much a hundred foot how much a
hundred foot sandwich would feed
think about that a hundred [ __ ] foot
holy [ __ ] that's a that's a that's a big
[ __ ] sandwich
ah that's a lot of sandwiches
but they were gonna have this hundred
foot long sandwich for their encampment
but it turns out zach reports here it
turns out it was all hoax
of course it was
as convoy members now claim antifa
extremists
were behind the sammich scam
so antifa extremist
scammed
the
1776 nazi movement that formerly known
as the people's convoy
with the sammich scam
i'm excited about this i don't know who
my antifa brothers and sisters were out
there your card the card carrying george
soros
antifa brigade was
that scammed
the people's convoy but i'm excited
about this story gabe said probably the
same antifa subs
that sank the manga boat parade that's
true you guys remember the the [ __ ]
maga boat thing where they had the all
the boats
and they all had maga flags there were
so many maga flags the wind
pushed the [ __ ] boat into the water
and it sank these boats you guys
remember that [ __ ] right
shanked the [ __ ] boats
and they blamed it on nt of course it
was george and antifa speaking of antifa
speaking of individual we have gabe
sanchez hey
you're uh you're a chapter president of
the antifa sandwich scam oh yeah three
mist those hundred foot long antifa subs
really really will will take you down
right right i think you could have an uh
a sandwich insurrection kind of thing
yeah absolutely tons of sandwiches you
know what now that i think about it
that's probably what's going to come out
on the january 6 select committee
hearings here oh is that antiva the
reason why antifa was not there that day
um to battle the the they were prepping
the sandwich they were prepping the sam
they were getting the sandwiches ready
for the insurrection god damn it right
extra mayo extra mayo
[Laughter]
who else who else is going to prep these
this sammich besides the antipa i don't
i don't i don't think anyone i mean
there's only one force that is strong
enough and willing
enough
to prepare a sandwich
that big
and that
what do you what do you think besides
mayo is on the same do you think it's
turkey and ham do you think it's like an
italian
no
i think italian is like a little too
spicy right oh okay yeah so i think what
they do is they probably put ham on for
sure sure right
uh i'm thinking like cold cut hams from
like a lunchables yeah okay so not not
really it's kind of like slimy type yeah
yeah yeah like it's it's
clearly manufactured that kind of like
it's got a little to it right i would
say that kind of ham tons of mayo
uh just a [ __ ] like like more mayo than
anything yeah yeah yeah not not not like
good iceberg lettuce like not real
crispy like
slimy yeah it's the one that's like at
the bottom it's like ugh right sitting
here right you know they also might try
to throw some raisins in you know i feel
like
that might be a thing there yeah that's
probably it you know i mean they love it
in their uh their potato salad or
whatever the [ __ ] it is all right right
right who's they who's they is it is it
the uh the the nazis the nazis liked
raisins in their nazi raisins nazi
reasons well you know it happens
what in the [ __ ] is this story what is
this what are you i know i actually
insane did they really believe this or
is this yeah from what i understand
i also wanted i also want to call it the
fact that they had renamed themselves to
the 1776 restoration like what is this a
[ __ ] fixer-upper
right
i mean
guys our big issue is branding we need
to rebrand again right so that people
take it seriously so it's gonna be 1776
restoration right well and that's the
other thing too is is this like a a
[ __ ] reality show on tlc or something
i
honestly i might watch an episode if it
was right the 1776 restoration
just the fact that they they're like you
know what this whole time no one has
really taken us seriously we're the butt
of a joke everyone's making videos about
us right there's these guys on the tony
michael's podcast made his
truckers convoy [ __ ] about us
they're like you know what
we need to get back at them and show
everyone that we're big boys right we're
wearing the big boy hats we're in the
big boy trucker hats
so what are you going to do
1776 restoration
oh wow do you think on the on the
reality tv show if they if we pitched it
could we do like sandwich um
competitions where they were building
100 foot sandwiches yes and what would
happen is like
antifa extremists could be throwing
things at them yeah no not real not real
well yeah not real anti-victim they
don't really exist but like fake andy no
kind
yeah know exactly like rubber rubber
dildos you know right those things right
but yes i think it could be like game
show-esque where you're like trying to
build it like kind of nickelodeon you
know where like you would be trying to
do a task and you'd be giving you things
like just like projectile at you right
we could you know we could even probably
get joe rogan
or like a wish.com joe rogan right yeah
yeah
right right right
you should probably find someone you
know maybe uh
who knows maybe ben shapiro will want to
show up you know he's like
okay
probably
99.97 feet uh this sub is disqualified
um
i think uh it is it is a show a reality
show that i could i could get behind
possibly i would consider watching at
least one episode just to see the
characters that are introduced
uh
i'm good because
i don't know there's an element of it
that's like this is so
crazy i would tune in for at least an
episode
i think i i think i think we should
pitch it to tlc oh you should i think we
should we could get on we get on tv game
because that's the goal here is to get
on tv right i mean it's not it's that's
bad enough we're on youtube i know
twitch hey we just moved up we're at
1080p baby we are
we are high def i don't know if anyone
noticed this
i'm much uglier this morning because
gabe convinced me over the weekend to
switch to 1080. i said let's let's throw
this away podcast into overdrive baby we
got the january 6 hearings coming up we
need to be high def that's right and i
switched it and i was like holy [ __ ]
we're going to lose viewers because i'm
so glad that they're going to see how
ugly i am and and
no man it's called being authentic oh is
that oh yeah wait wait wait so it's not
that i'm not ugly it's that no no
no no of course no it's not it's not
that you're not ugly it's just you being
authentic you're being your true self
you know you know [ __ ] them but [ __ ]
them hd [ __ ] em hd that's hey that's a
good we should we should cut a
commercial [ __ ] em hd now in 1080 we've
finally joined the future [ __ ] [ __ ] them
in 1080. i don't know maybe maybe we'll
go [ __ ] on 4k here soon uh speaking
speaking of uh the january 6 uh
committee hearings you you brought it up
that they will be in 1080p
uh january 6 committee hearings start
thursday eastern at 8 pm now we're gonna
start our broadcast at seven because
we're gonna do an hour's worth of
commentary before uh michael popocket
posted here minus touch network will be
gavel the gavel live streaming with the
rotating group of midas mighty analysts
commenting in real time including
michael popock ben mizellis kfa karen
agnipolo and b tony michaels
i don't know if i'm a single expert
where am i
i i shouldn't i shouldn't be on this
list anyways what is going on i'm not
i'm not i'm not i'm not a legal expert
i mean
i i just run the show so we're we're
going to be producing the show for midas
touch and we're going to air this uh all
these hearings over uh on their youtube
channel so go follow
midas touch also follow us on youtube as
well if you want that's cool yeah you're
not you're not gonna you don't want to
miss anything even
the the every episode every single
weekday you don't want to miss any of
that yeah yeah but you're definitely not
going to want to miss these hearings so
we'll have a special coverage on
thursday starting at 7 00 p.m eastern
we will have those rotating group of
midas mighty analyst as kopok says there
now with the legal af team and probably
even the mind is touch podcast team with
jordy yeah yeah and i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be taking the show on the road
technically that that's that is true
because you have you have a you you have
a uh wedding i think that you're
attending i have no i have a a bachelor
a friend oh okay so it is a party prior
to the wedding right exactly yeah yeah
well i don't know
now is this like a matt walsh type um
ben shapiro charlie kirk type bachelor
party is that what this is nope nope
these are just oh really
nice empathy oh okay so
progressive
okay so there'll be there'll be no
there'll be no
trans or home homophobes there
uh spewing
the place that we're staying so okay
good good good but i will be there could
depending on the situation in the house
in terms of like people playing music
you may see me in my car so if you
notice like hey gabe's not in his room
anymore you know this sounds suspicious
it sounds like you're making up stories
it sounds like what is happening is you
are part of the antifa sandwich
extremist and you're preparing
sandwiches somewhere
for this january 6th select committee
hearing
and it feels like i don't know so join
us join us this thursday
at 7 pm eastern we'll put out the link
that link will be available we'll widely
distribute that link so you guys can
find that link for that first hearing um
gabe sanchez is on
on the art today he's getting that
thumbnail ready so we can get that link
to you so you guys can work
he's working on this um on the art here
um
speaking of working
did you see elon musk didn't you see
this he's scary yeah he's
he is uh
he's really making it man i
i'm like
in between right in this peter navarro
what was that bit and i have it i have a
a pre-written
elon musk bit it just keeps it but it
stays the same right it doesn't mean
it's the same but he's adding he
predicted yeah yeah but what he's doing
is he's adding more
more fodder for me to add in
to this segment of like why you know
when i
basically when i say like it's not gonna
happen i mean it all started i started
writing this was supposed to be my first
what was that segment on elon musk
when that hand job that was the first
that was the first first one that was
supposed to be the first one
and then i
i put it on pause and then the shooting
happened and i was like you know what
i'm gonna focus on this first
but yeah uh i mean the whole the intro
was supposed to be about hand jobs for
horses which i think still is totally
relevant
well i i think it's relevant too uh elon
musk tweeted uh over the weekend he said
some hate humanity but i love humanity
so much yeah
and i said would you trade a horse for
it i i don't know
i mean if he loves it so much i mean i'm
sure
humanity is for horses yeah
for humanities whichever you know
everything you want these handies where
he handies were horses and humanity for
horses exactly i figured that was a fair
question he never answered me
i mean i think it's econ 101 really you
know right ask all those maga finance
bros like look if i were to give you a
horse and you were to give me a handy is
that a fair trade is that humanity by
the way
is that that humanity i don't know i
mean i should just rename the bit what
was that too is that humanity is that
humanity i don't know i i
he never got back to me though elon
never told me if he would trade a horse
for humanity i i don't i don't think he
will he's i don't think he will he's a
little scaredy yeah
speaking of other [ __ ] you got
herschel walker uh wait herschel walker
is illegally buying votes no way
sounds like the gop's ideal candidate um
so over the weekend it looked like i
guess this is a former staffer from
waffler's game yeah yeah yeah so you
already know this guy is uh is top notch
right oh he's oh he's he's creme de la
creme in the dark manga world i'm sure
yeah and i'm sure he's not a bonehead oh
a hundred percent
um he says huge morning for the pack
because they're they're promoting a pack
here it's 34 in 22 pack what is that i
don't know what that means uh
let's see does that mean they're gonna
get 34 seats in 22 is that what they're
that's what they're saying i don't know
um anyways they're giving away
over four thousand dollars because he
that's what i thought he was number 34.
oh oh i was
34. i don't know what the n stands for
this pack is specifically set up
for herschel walker
is what you're saying
oh you know what you know what i think
it is it's 34 herschel walker in 22
right like 34. vote for him in 2022
exactly so it's for him specifically
yeah yeah um and this bonehead tweets
while warnock isn't working we're
reaching out
showing up and giving back to the
african-american community something
herschel walker
will do every day as georgia's next u.s
senator
joe
apparently
they were handing out what seemed to be
felony checks
um because not only are they handing out
checks for free gas they're handing out
flyers in support
of herschel walker which seems to be
which seems to be coordination also
seems to be buying votes which a super
pac cannot do they can't actually buy
votes they can use their money to
influence votes but not buy it
it really is kind of gross here yeah
but i mean that's a true republican
right you you lie you cheat you steal
and you kill
right well and the other thing too is
this
this this underhanded um
herschel walker is blacker than warnock
kind of thing here going on like this is
kind of that's kind of gross too the
whole you know you know the giving back
to the african-american like we're
giving checks that are felonies
yeah the african-american community
which i mean who wouldn't take free gas
though yeah honestly i mean but also
four thousand dollars in free gas like
if they're giving away 25 gift cards
like you're only getting so many people
before like oops sorry guess you should
have been first in line right i think is
a very republican way to look at that
because they're like right yes you
should have pulled yourself out of your
bootstraps and gotten here first thing
in the morning right are known about it
so we could take a pictures for our
photo our felony photo ops because
really literally that's kind of what
they did is they took photo ops and like
the photo proof
of them holding their certificates and
the pant book that they're giving them
in support of herschel walker
is
apparently uh it seems illegal it just i
mean not to bring it back to january 6
but it's the same type of mentality that
all of those people especially the proud
boys oath keepers everyone else involved
that were storming the capital
documented themselves
at the capitol inside outside committing
these crimes and then people were like
wait why is the fbi showing at my house
it's like well you had your work badge
on you in a photo that you posted on
your facebook account that had your full
name and your address so you're pretty
[ __ ] dumb
speaking of [ __ ] insurrectionist
boneheads who go on tv and admit their
guilt did you see this [ __ ] oh
yeah oh i got peter navarro as everyone
knows is a whack-a-doo straight [ __ ]
whack-a-doo like steve bannon has him on
his show
just to display the wackiness like a zoo
almost
and steve bannon sometimes can't even
believe that this guy is dysfucking
wacky and he goes on ari melber's show a
lot on msnbc
and he starts admitting admitting crimes
that he's committed like
and the other thing too that ari points
out a lot of times is this [ __ ] guy
will come on tv and say the things that
he says he can't say because of
executive privilege in a committee
hearing yeah and he's like why that what
and he's he does it every [ __ ] time
and ari's like what why in the [ __ ] do
you think the committee shouldn't hear
what you're saying or can't hear what
you're saying this is on tv man this is
not a problem this is being broadcasted
to millions of people right and you are
just giving it out for free this [ __ ]
guy
he literally is saying the things that
the january 6 select committee want to
hear on air right like they want to hear
under subpoena under oath and he's
saying it on aaron and but the problem
is is he's claiming executive privilege
well if it's actual executive privilege
you couldn't say it on [ __ ] national
television right goddamn dummy
he really is a bonehead but the best
part about this
is he's such a [ __ ] crybaby these
these [ __ ] maga dark mark they act
like we're [ __ ] snowflakes and all
this [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] he he gets
arrested because he gets indicted
on charges that he knew he was gonna get
indicted on gabe they knew it yeah and
the reason why is because the committee
subpoenaed him he told them to go [ __ ]
themselves they had a special hearing
to request
the doj
to charge him with contempt of congress
congress then voted on it like this
isn't like it was done in the dark of
the night and no one knew this [ __ ]
literally
it all was done out in the [ __ ] open
right
i think the funniest part about this is
how he was like look look look i mean
i'm sure we'll play it in this clip but
he's like look guys guys i would have
shown up i live right down the road if
the fbi wanted me to come in i would
have done it totally but then they
intercepted me i love how you
intercepted intercepted me as i was
getting on the plane why were you
getting on the plane peter navarro he
claims he was going to some other
function in another state yeah i think
i'm like
or some [ __ ] your definition flight risk
bro
you're right definition flight risk and
you're like they could have just told me
to come over and it's like no i i think
you knew this was coming
and you tried to [ __ ] bail and before
you tried to bail you went on the rml
brochure and you're like hey listen guys
here's this crime
right admitting to it
and then he's like all right see you
guys later
now let's watch this bonehead and let's
listen to him cry his mock tears this
[ __ ] [ __ ] i told them yeah
contact an individual who
who would discuss this map
what did they do
you are the individual you dummy
he's like who is this individual
who is this individual one of the
subpoenas
right like
usually someone say i i told him to
contact my attorney he doesn't say that
he says this individual he's
representing himself so i don't know who
he's telling them to come well maybe
maybe it's rudy giuliani and he can't
say attorney because rudy giuliani isn't
an attorney anymore i don't know i have
no idea you know all these people are
losing their law license because they're
outside oh man it is beautiful though
is this the kraken is this the releasing
is this is this the cracking you know
it's kind of like when people are like
oh trump is going to drain the swamp you
know inadvertently
by his own doing he is sort of draining
the swamp
by the involvement of others and what
they attempted with the coup like we're
pulling these people out and being like
all right you got this guy this guy this
guy this woman this woman these are all
bad people and they're draining the
swamp that way as opposed to trump going
in and being like we got to get these
democrats out of here they're the part
of the swamp it's like not bro you
filled that [ __ ] up and now it's
overflowing and we're taking people out
i just it's i i really maybe i don't
think this is the kraken but it just
it's
it really is pathetic about how he
almost cries gabe watch he almost cries
they didn't call me i spoke to
the fbi agent normally when they arrest
you they don't call you
wednesday night i said walter
whatever you need you don't have to come
banging on my door like you did last
week getting me out of bed i'm here to
cooperate oh really because that's funny
because you're actually charged with
contempt of congress congress because
you're not cooperating right i don't
understand what the guys guys just i
would have cooperated if you told me
it's like oh one
that probably i'm not saying he would
have shredded documents or gotten rid of
stuff but i'm saying he would have
shredded documents got rid of stuff like
i i look at this
and for the guy that says
i'm not willing to uh
to
to actually
listen to this subpoena i'm just gonna
ignore it like it's some it's like jury
duty you know he's like look i never got
the i never got the mail i never got the
email never got the notice and he's like
why do people start banging on my door
why they intercept you with my plane
it's like why the [ __ ] do you think it's
been publicly known it's been told to
you on tv there is a subpoena for you
and you were like i'm not going to do it
it
he's a such a [ __ ] whiny little [ __ ]
dark pepsi uh with the super chat here
is dark pepsi the one that is yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah dark pepsi is the one
my ugly ass being in 1080p so for
context i saw dark pepsi said a comment
and then i sent that comment to uh tony
and i said hey people want it
and then he was like you're painting my
ass
that's what i said to me to me not to
dark bread he said it to me because i
had previously said we should turn the
show into hd do the 1080 baby not that
720.
so we over the weekend we turned it to
1080. we dialed it into the whole thing
oh it was uh was it wasn't he screwed up
the whole thing it took me like an hour
to fix the damn thing yeah so i wasn't
like zoomed in i was way in like you
were wait like you were it was you could
see tony's eye the whole right right it
was just all you could see dark pepsi
thank you for the super chat and thank
you for the
1080p suggestion i guess
i guess
making me on the
1080p
it's just more it's just more for people
to love you know i'm just glad i'm just
glad i'm small most of the time on the
screen here okay let's finish let's
finish with dip [ __ ] here okay
what did they do yeah i was on my way
they're gonna arrest you today oh my god
do a tv appearance with mike huckabee's
show right okay number one you should be
arresting people just flying to
nashville to do mike huckabee like that
should be a thing like we shouldn't let
these people be going and doing mike
huckabee show in the first place let
alone peter navarro this [ __ ]
this self-admitted traitor on on
national tv
uh but yeah
i'm surprised he was going to go see
this is what doesn't make yeah there's
part of me that doesn't make sense here
right he does all these other shows
with his green screen right
and then he's saying that he's going to
fly to go do mike huckabee show i have a
hard time believing that because any
time it's newsmax fox news
msnbc like any of the shows he's always
in front of a green screen because he
could just put nashville behind him and
yeah he could do whatever he could he
could do a night night skyline of
nashville right no one would know the
difference well i mean he everyone would
he decided this one time
when this [ __ ] was heating up that he
had to fly to go do mike huckabee show i
don't believe it
well i mean maybe he took his green
screen with him maybe yeah he's maybe
that's why he's man
you don't you gotta do the green screen
in the studio yeah yeah it's a whole
thing right right it's something i do
like you're standing next to me why do i
need the [ __ ] green is it gonna
it's we we we gotta
even though i'm here i can't really be
here you know right right right because
that's a thing
and instead of coming
to my door
where i live which by the way is right
next to the fbi he lives right next to
the fbi
like is he talking like an fbi agent is
across the hall from him or he lives
like his house is right next to the fbi
building i don't know he probably like
looks across his alleyway and he's got
an fbi agent just like right right he's
like they're right next door like
they're right there always i see them
everywhere they've been watching me
every [ __ ] day since january 6th
they're tapping my phone for crying out
loud i gotta stay in my house and green
screen every place i'm at because i
can't leave because they're there is
that what he means i don't know i think
so it's just very weird that you'd be
like i'm moving next door to the fbi
like i'm pretty sure there's a bit of a
boundary that you've got going on here
right right but surely surely he means
like on the same block or
right but even fbi building that's down
i mean like unless he's in some sort of
high-rise like fbi's
typically those buildings are in uh the
city right well i mean he's talking
about washington dc because he was
arraigned in dc i think right
now now i gotta look up where oh yeah go
look that [ __ ] up let's let's finish
listening to mcbonehead here instead of
calling me and say hey we need you it
looks like he's gonna cry
if you've got a warrant for you i would
have gladly come what did they do they
intercepted me getting on the plane oh
they put me in handcuffs they bring me
here they put me in leg irons oh my god
they put him in handcuffs and leg irons
oh
oh the travesty he's standing on the
[ __ ] sidewalk right like he didn't
have a cop kneel on his neck yeah and
and and kneel on him until he couldn't
breathe and he died they put handcuffs
on him gabe and leg irons oh my god this
is another part that does not make sense
to me he didn't have leg iron do not
believe he had
i don't even know if he had handcuffs
maybe
but i definitely don't think he had leg
irons on he's not a [ __ ] murderer no
[ __ ] way did they put lego i mean
unless they were just [ __ ] with him
which i can understand you know they've
been living next door to him spying on
him back in years or
over a year to try to [ __ ] catch this
guy because he won't come out cause he's
standing in front of his green screen
like peter
come out come out
so maybe they did [ __ ] with him and put
leg irons i doubt it though i did i just
seriously doubt that they put [ __ ]
leg arms on this guy no [ __ ] way guy
he's like guys again he's like guys they
they came after me when i was trying to
flee the country right to go do mike
huckabee's show i was going to locate
nashville nashville nashville mexico
nashville mexico i was going to a
country with no extradition right right
so i could do the show but i've got my
green screen with me
do you notice they all wear the the red
you know the thing here in this video
that i that we don't normally have with
peter navarro is he didn't take the suit
jacket off and roll his sleeves up maybe
that's why he's so [ __ ] here this is
because he doesn't have the the sleaze
roll that that's like his superpower
right i know well that's the thing so
like that's a definitely a first part of
my bit that i do in the new segment oh
okay yeah was that which is about the
rolled up sleeves right because he
reminds me of certain types because he's
always got his sleeves always guys
whenever he's on
the green
whenever he's okay the only time he
wears a suit coat is like when he's
doing a public appearance like he was in
the press uh
uh press conference room in the white
house or he was doing outside the white
house doing interview or in this
situation but anytime he goes and does a
show newsmax fox news whatever
white shirt
red or a blue tie
rolled up sleeves
like that's
that he's like getting he's getting in
the weeds he's got his green screen up
and he's talking about this image of uh
you know the cdc or it's a labor force
or it's uh the kremlin or whatever it is
he's got something rolled up sleeves
ready to go
and get his hands dirty he's such a
[ __ ] dangling he's a he's a he's a
weirdo
so i looked it up the fbi building in
the j edgar hoover building is downtown
right so he would have to live in
so he was in a high rise he would have
to live in a high-rise downtown right
and and he's probably got fbi agents
that live in the high rise walter as he
says because you've got the doj across
from the j edgar hoover so then he's
somewhere nearby if he's saying that he
listens to he's like on the same block
or two right right when he when he's
saying when he's saying that he lives
next to the fbi that's about as much of
the truth is he had nothing to do with
the insurrection like that's about as
much of the truth you know and maybe not
really not yeah let's finish they stick
me in himself by the way
that's what they do to criminals i was
in john hinckley oh my god
historical note brush your shoulders
what they did look at the guy behind him
what is this have we ever figured out
what this sign says there's another yeah
there's another video where it actually
shows him let me see if i can see if you
pull up a photo of this sign i want to
read the sign he today
violated the constitution
and by the way this guy behind him with
the sign he looks like the doorman for
the for the action like he's the doorman
at this bill maybe it's at his building
where next to the fbi is where this guy
i mean because he's kind of got that
the the hat and the best on yeah really
does look like a doorman and he's got
this sign i want to know what that sign
says in my lawsuit in my lawsuit i
discuss going back
to nixon
gsa and other cases
that what this government is supposed to
do when they have an issue such as
they've had
this is not the first rodeo they've had
they've had plenty of people more word
salad here
what they're supposed to do is take the
least burdensome alternative
i told him
he told them go negotiate yeah
with donald john trump
and his attorneys because i'm in an
untenable constitutional position
there's no civil law on this
there's no i mean i'm on tenable
position i've said this on tv i keep
repeating the same stuff that i won't
tell a committee on tv and told them
that this stuff is your testimony
executive privilege and presidents
trump's right
to executive privilege what did they do
this is really dumb this is this is more
horse [ __ ]
more horse [ __ ] from these guys um uh
thanks for the super chat cap says for
calling
rittenhouse what he is a murderer we're
gonna get to that story i want to get
your take on the uh
m did you find a picture of the uh yeah
i'm looking for the video
uh
oh somebody else i want to be able to
read that sign that was behind him yeah
yeah i know there's a video because i've
seen it right
because this guy seems like he's
protesting
yeah like he was waiting for peter
navarro to come out of the uh
the courthouse here um as he was after
his arraignment uh and his indictment
because that's what would happen is they
arrested him just to arraign him right
because they indicted him on these
charges just like they did steve bannon
now steve bannon actually
self-surrendered himself because he
wasn't hopping on a plane to nashville
right yeah nashville yeah i don't
believe man i i i really believe he was
trying to fill russia if he's got a
green screen he could have done the
whole interview from home right while
the fbi agents were watching absolutely
you
know
right next door apparently
um but no this this [ __ ] bonehead and
it's gonna continue with these [ __ ]
where they're they continue to make up
these stories and this [ __ ] about
why and why not apparently you know
we're going to we're going to stream the
january 6 hearings but i guess maga
maga is going to be streaming these
hearings and they're gonna give their
republican take on
why the the hearings aren't accurate and
all this [ __ ] as they're going on that
should be very interesting like despite
the fact that you know several of us
were chatting directly with uh mark
meadows right right the text message is
for mark meadows i think is going to be
uh a key part of the evidence okay the
sign says
uh he's a conductor oh okay okay yeah
stop hating each other
because you disagree
and then it says truth conductor and
then he's recording that's what it says
stop hating each other because you
disagree truth conductor so the uniform
is that he's a conductor
right so now i'm thinking this is a
uniform
oh okay so this guy this guy is not new
to this yeah
yeah yeah like he's got a twitter
account he's a messenger from god of
course okay oh jesus oh jesus well find
his twitter account give it to me and
then later on we'll we'll retweet some
stuff from from the truth conductor i
i'm very fascinated by this guy now i
want to know more i want to know more
about this individual this
this this truth conductor um
speaking of truth and untruth
and someone just
gave a super chat for uh
kyle rittenhouse did you see the video
of him declaring he was going to uh
texas a m have you seen i did not see
that one what i have seen are uh two
videos previously from the turning point
usa one of which he was there with a dog
and the guy was talking about how you
need to have a man that wants to protect
you like kylo ren house now what then i
watched kyle
what now what what was it what was that
what was it
there was a video of him on stage with a
what looks like he's got a dog maybe
golden retriever i couldn't see is this
the young women's leadership thing yeah
yeah but there's also another video
which is kind uh kaylee mcinanny's
sister
creates an app that's called um
uh it's called
just right swipe right
um i forget what it's called but it's a
it's a right wing only
um
dating app
that's going to be coming out soon oh
nice so this is like a maga dating app
you know i did another i didn't know i
did that
well because they all failed right right
right right
it just like true social yeah was a
great success um here is here's the clip
on charlie kirk's trader tv
show where he actually
he he puts on a hat from texas a m watch
watch this video of kyle rittenhouse
lying to charlie kirk's audience which
is not surprising he's ready to make
this like
he's ready to make it wow everybody it's
a big deal oh yeah right here in the
charlie cook show you know i should just
like buy hats for colleges and just
start putting them on that's it that's
incredible the enthusiasm behind charlie
kirk's voice is wow
that's a very important stuff yeah texas
a m like like if he's if he put on a
yale head he's like wow yale right kyle
where did the girl where did the girl uh
with the ar-15 go
the what where was you remember the
blonde girl
who had the ar-15
where did she go
who are you talking about the
uh
hopefully someone in the comments can
tell me i'm gonna look it up right now
let's see ar 15 i'm just gonna type
blonde girl
i honestly don't caitlyn bennett caitlyn
bennett
who is that you don't remember caitlyn
bennett kent state that's who it is she
was known for carrying an ar-10 at kent
state oh okay so it wasn't texas a m no
no no but it was a photo because she had
it she what it was is the photo was her
with a it was graduation
and uh she's got an ar10 wrapped around
her shoulder she's in a white kind of
dress skirt thing as she's going to
uh
going to graduation i think it was
but yeah and her hat said
come and take it
i'm going to take yeah
so kent state is in ohio
that's where i i have some friends that
went to kent state
um in ohio is where it's at so you know
this is uh
this is i just send you a link and then
maybe if you see it you'll be like oh
what oh wait hold on that worked well
let's let's finish the uh murderer here
uh making his fake announcement for
texas and then we'll go to the picture
kyle rittenhouse is announcing that he's
an aggie
so i'm going to be going there it's
going to be awesome
he gave you
now if you were going to pick a college
right if you're going to pick a college
you would have a lot of reasons this
[ __ ] picks he he pretends to
pick texan a m because of chicken strips
i'm not [ __ ] you
this [ __ ] little murderous child this
little petulant little [ __ ] yeah says he
picks texas a m because of chicken
strips listen to this
beautiful campus yeah amazing people
uh-huh amazing food food um we went to
dixie's chicken there dixie's chicken
man they have a great chicken strip
basket they have a great chicken strip
basket man listen listen
best burgers i've ever that's why he's
going dixie's chicken everybody now you
know what they say at a m they say
giggum gig them and you know how they
say hello they say howdy howdy
so there you go and
so you're gonna you're gonna be are you
gonna join the corps of cadets i haven't
decided yet i may um you know what you
the best part about this is texas a m
has released a statement they're like
[ __ ] this guy this guy is not coming
this guy is not coming to you can go to
dick's chicken all you want and did they
release a statement
yeah yeah they said no he's not coming
to texas
holy [ __ ] are you serious
when i [ __ ] you you're my favorite turd
i mean i don't know man you might
sprinkle on a little fairy dust on top
of my [ __ ] here favorite [ __ ] turd i
would not [ __ ] you i'm telling god that
is amazing so he lied
is that surprising no not at all he was
the one who also said he wasn't he was
in school for uh to be a paramedic and
then he
and it was a private online or was a it
was university of phoenix right
i
you got me man
you got me is this that is this the uh
kent state so this is caitlin bennett
this is the one that had the ar15
graduation boom come and take it that
same type [ __ ] what is this what is
this does this even mean i don't even
know what to do
what is she protesting here
i don't know she's like
it's so what is she what is she proving
here is she trying to be cute or is she
trying to be tough
because it really it really is [ __ ]
these these [ __ ] people with these
gun boomers because you've seen the poll
44 of republicans right the school
shootings just ah it's just the thing
we're going to have to which is it you
know on it like i was hoping that the
shootings would have some sort of
turning point for these people you know
not turning points oh well i mean i mean
i mean it actually i mean i believe that
they're that it's made them believe that
hey we have to really we have to really
put forth this narrative that these
school shootings are going to happen
it's a good guy bad guy [ __ ] you know
it's all it's all cool because i mean
it's not it shouldn't be surprising
because if you think about it you had
the same people that during covid
despite the fact that there was research
and data that said hey
this can have some serious effects
especially the novel strain of the virus
they go that is what it is now you know
what hey if you live you live and if you
don't well hey
sucks to suck it really
this is the same thing they're just like
oh well sucks this up you got shot up
and it's like what the [ __ ]
so so if you can't see let me let me
move the banner here so you can see
it the top of her because that's her
graduation hat yeah right and on the top
of the head it says come and take it now
this is obviously she is so tough gabe
she's so tough that she posed for this
picture right
it's not like she went to the graduation
with this gun she's posing for a picture
to make it seem like she went to the
graduation with the gun i'm almost i'm
almost certain that the kent state would
not let her walk with the gun
during her graduation ceremony so this
is more cosplay [ __ ] this is more
standing in front of a christmas tree
gun boner grooming that the republican
party does the death cult does who think
44 of them just think ah well we just
have to put up with school shootings
that's just right our children just have
to
[ __ ] put up with getting murdered we
just have to put up with that that's the
thing that's for our freedom those
children are sacrificed for our freedom
i mean we usually talk about veterans
and soldiers and you know yeah and
foreign speaking of veterans and
soldiers you've got uh you know lindsey
graham last week who said you know what
we should do
is we should arm the veterans and
soldiers who have come back who might be
experiencing ptsd who are not going to
help in benefit with you know health
care or proper resources and we're going
to say you know what you need we're
going to employ you again but we're
going to make you the guards at the
schools with the guns in a high stress
environment so when a bad guy comes in
with the gun you're the good guy with
the gun which is like one how many
veterans do you think are out there that
are capable of doing this and two
did you ever think at one point when you
wrote that tweet and then said yeah
i [ __ ] got those libs that it was a
good idea that you were like this is
totally flawless this will never fail
and they will always win and stop the
bad guy with the gun despite or or
they'll be like oh [ __ ] this is a high
stress environment
i should not put this person who might
be already susceptible or
uh
or at you know at stress
in this situation
because they might not be able to
actually
do what you've hired them to do
well
in in and you've already there was
plenty dozens of police officers
right to handle this situation we seen
over the weekend there was 12 more
people who were killed in mass shooting
events right where more than three
people were shot
it
i mean and these people like ah this is
just inevitable we can't do anything
about it because the gun the handful of
families in this country that own gun
manufacturers we just have to appease
them
we just have to appease them with
nonsense it's [ __ ] lies it's all lies
you know they they they do this with
everything yeah
even even like in this case of this
massachusetts gop nominee for secretary
of state because that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to overturn
our elections
um have you seen have you seen this uh
rayla campbell have you seen this video
this person uh over the weekend she was
at a republican
she was at a republican nazi rally um
listen to what listen to what she says
at the very end it's not very long now
this again this is the gop nominee for
listen
secretary of state of massachusetts this
person is the one they want in charge of
elections listen to this really weird
[ __ ] she says it's really [ __ ] weird
that she even has these thoughts to say
out of her pie hole
you can't just sit and go oh
that's terrible maybe somebody else will
take care of it oh that's not so nice
well i don't think it's nice when
they're telling your five-year-old that
he can go and suck another
five-year-old's dick do you did you hear
that
this this is not this is not some kind
of [ __ ] full-blown homophobia huh
this is not this is not some [ __ ]
this is not some gotcha video
she is in front of a microphone speaking
at a republican event as the nominee
yeah the gop nominee for secretary of
state i'm gonna back it up here you
cannot look away this vile piece of [ __ ]
not only is she doing the homophobia
thing but she's talking about
five-year-olds
right listen they they constantly say
this nonsense this nonsense like the
don't say gay bill in florida where
where a child can't say that they have
two moms or they have two days they
can't say that right they can't they
cannot acknowledge the environment that
they grow up right it doesn't exist tony
right it doesn't exist they're just a
person that's grooming that's [ __ ]
gross that's sexual right
this is the mind of the person who is
who is going to try to be a
an acting policy now
specifically in massachusetts on
elections
listen to this [ __ ] weirdo say this
phrase in front of a microphone
well i don't think it's nice when
they're telling your five-year-old that
he can go and suck another
five-year-old's dick do you
how in the [ __ ] did we just be the
attitude to be like
do you
like
when
if ever
has a five-year-old ever gone to do that
and
when have they ever gone to do it in
numbers oh oh god jesus christ of course
explore talent
this is the same place that you find
people like candace owens and lauren
beaubert before they became the
political uh personalities that they are
i'm just pointing this out i'm just
pointing this out i
i'm not i'm not saying anything specific
i mean i would never begrudge someone to
put their profile on
exploretalent.com but why in the [ __ ]
are they selecting their [ __ ]
candidates from explore talent.com why
why could it be could it be that they're
paying people for gas and they're paying
people to be candidates i don't know
yeah i have no idea how am i supposed to
know but that's what the that's what the
people do and speaking of which we'll go
to transition here dark pepsi brings up
that in la county yes we do have uh
primaries that are that are happening
you can go and vote right now yeah
that's tomorrow right yeah yeah yeah
tomorrow's voting day is the actual well
we have no we i mean we have voting
that's open right now right but tomorrow
is actually yeah right right yeah the
polls are open and closed tomorrow
exactly and uh yeah and so rick caruso
if you anyone lives out there i can't
tell you how to vote i would just say i
wouldn't support rick russo he's a
billionaire
uh republican turned democrat that wants
to put more money into the police and
wants to does he have an
uh i wouldn't be surprised if he did you
know i'm just i'm just um but yeah he's
he's someone there are better options
the reality is he will probably make it
to the like he will probably make it as
a primary candidate but uh
we could do our part to to not make it
that way there's there's a few people
that are the top runners right now
uh well we have if you're in l.a
practice
go you have to go practice this
um
it is
there's all kinds of craziness that is
going on but uh speaking of crazy ass
candidates that you need to be aware of
uh might as touch you know you guys know
we're proud partners of mine and such
they did a a video on herschel walker
speaking of the uh
the scandal where the super pac is
possibly committing felonies by buying
buying people's votes let's watch this
video from mind as touch about herschel
walker here
marshall walker is running for the
georgia senate and his run has
highlighted not only his lack of
qualifications but the raft of bizarre
things that have come out of his mouth
georgia senate candidate herschel walker
is making headlines after his comments
about evolution one time science said
man came from apes
if that is true
why are there still apes
think about it
and people say first you play football
but i see guys i also was in the top one
percent of my graduating class in
college not only was he not in the top
one percent he didn't even graduate from
the university of georgia
on brand on brand police in irving texas
once confiscated a gun from him
following a demand i want to point out
that the uh the whole
didn't go to georgia didn't graduate
that's on brand we just seen this from
kyle rittenhouse yeah this is this is on
brand type stuff he's gonna tell us he's
gonna tell us he's like guys uh
look i walked my first hand campus and
they already gave me diploma i graduated
top of my class right one of one right
right well you know this is
this it's insanity that they they're
like oh all these educated elites out
there they go to their colleges and they
become liberals and they tell us what to
do because they're elites and then
they're like yeah i i'm gonna go to a
university and i'm gonna get edumacated
and i'm i'm gonna go to texas a m texas
a m is like no you're not and hershel i
graduated first my class in in georgia
well no you didn't you did not you did
not graduate you listen these are all
lies
you live
you live
in a pool of lies you lie in a bed of
lies but it's just so hilarious that
they hate educated college educated
elites listen i'm a two-time college
dropout i'm i'll admit it on air i'm a
two-time college dropout there's nothing
to be ashamed of herschel that you
didn't get that you didn't get educated
in georgia it's okay it's okay if you
dropped out there's nothing wrong with
that and kyle just because texas a m
told you to go get [ __ ] i'm sure
you'll be able to find
the prager university address online
you'll be able to go online and go to
prageru let's finish
domestic disturbance because they said
the former football star talked about
having a quote shootout with police
they can bring you into a building
that will clean you from covert as you
walk through this dry mix
maybe because it doesn't work
i just have to point out i just have to
point out that they use that they use
gem acosta they're just a [ __ ] dunk
on that [ __ ] yeah i like this i
like this sports kind of kind of yeah to
this video it's different right like
it's different i don't know i we all
know that brett kind of puts these
videos together i don't know if brad did
this one maybe he did or maybe i don't i
don't know if he did brett if you're
listening if he did this video it's i i
like the sports theme you should
continue to do those very interesting
let's let's finish let's see what else
boneheaded lies that this guy's told
he really nails him walker told the
atlanta business chronicle he was not
relying on ppp or the government to save
his chicken business but a few weeks
later walker's company benefited from
about 180 thousand dollars in ppp money
right now
i didn't know okay oh they recruited me
but for usc one thing you can do is help
the mentor some of the young kids that's
coming up in this uh athletic world oh
that was a disgrace
i mean who was who doesn't want to be
you know mentored by
herschel walker or o.j simpson yeah yeah
they kind of have uh oj's like look look
if i were to do it if i were to mention
right right this is how i would do it
right this is how i and he probably
wrote a book on how he would do it if
how would i mentor her
if i did it not to say that he would
just if he would yeah walker wrote a
book with some chilling passages
all i could think was how satisfying it
would feel to squeeze the trigger the
visceral enjoyment i'd get from seeing
the small entry wound and the spray of
brain tissue and blood like a fourth of
july firework exploding behind him he he
wrote this in a book
yeah
wait wait a second he wrote this [ __ ] in
a book that this
yeah
i know this guy this guy's got to have a
so they hired a ghostwriter to talk
about how he wants to blow someone's
brains out
yeah they uh you know they they took he
was like look this is my life you know
it's all there on the table like maybe
we don't say this he goes no no we we
gotta
people need to know people need to know
that i'm a real person i'm a great
person people gotta know they're like
yeah but this is like not like what an
average person would do right and
they're like right he's like uh no no
put it in the book put in the book he
wants to be authentic gabe he wants to
be authentic uh where he fantasizes
about
blowing someone's brains out this is
[ __ ] weird
u.s senate candidate herschel walker is
canceling a fundraiser after the
organizer faced backlash for using a
swastika well walker's campaign
originally defended her saying it was
clearly an anti-vaccine mandate graphic
really is that what that is
really is it is it really that's weird
you could have you could have put
syringes and or like ebony needles into
any sort of combination of a design and
you chose to do a swastika well i think
i think what they're saying there is
that that the vaccines are nazis right
that they're right i think
they're like oh i'm putting on my star
dave and it's like oh boy that is right
it's all projection it's all projection
from these [ __ ] because the
same the same people who hate the
vaccine are the ones protesting disney
world and and the ron desantis
supporters that are protesting disney
world are are actually holding up real
swastikas on flags like nazi flags in
disney world like there's there's
there's proof that these ronda santa
supporters these let's go brandon nazis
are going to disney world and protesting
so the venn diagram is just a circle
it's just a complete circle there is no
there is no like little thing on the
ends here right in the middle it's it's
completely
a circle right and sometimes in art you
know you like a certain look of
something so you you you tend to design
yeah i think a lot of what you you uh
you interact with has influence on
design so it's like it's almost weird
it's like there must have been some sort
of
icons or symbols or maybe a book you
were reading flags hanging on the wall
or yeah you know or it's like things you
look at before you go to bed things you
look at when you first wake up things
that might flag above your bed yeah
oh my god these [ __ ] people
played russian roulette i played russian
before and then more than one russia
russia russia russia russia i'm just
pointing that out here
that that we had to get the russia thing
in here come on
russia russia russia russia russian
roulette russia russia now this this is
this is actually kind of disturbing that
um that he's like yeah just nonchalantly
this guy's like really are you sure you
want to say that you were confirming
that you're such a dumb ass that you
were playing yeah sure yeah absolutely
oh my god if people came to my house to
compete against me
i would take a gun put a bullet in it
and spin it put it in my head and pull
the trigger wouldn't even think about it
herschel walker spoke with axios okay
let me ask you something let me ask you
something gabe if you were good at my
roommate well um
i i'm gonna ask you that here in a
minute after the video but if you were
gonna if you were gonna support someone
and you were gonna go vote for somebody
right and you really wanted to know what
kind of policy they were gonna set forth
you'd go to their house maybe if you're
gonna be a true supporter you're gonna
give them a lot of money knock on the
door right you go in and the first thing
this guy does just to prove that he's a
tough guy is to pull the trigger arm a
gun now would you trust that person
would you trust that person with i don't
know like policy for maybe a thing like
gun safety oh you trust that totally
yeah i would totally trust that guy
absolutely i mean without a doubt
without any sort of quiver or hesitation
i would say you are my guy right for gun
safety and not only that not only that
would you trust the guy that does that
to actually sit and think about policy
that would affect gas prices the economy
interest rates yeah yeah would you
really would you really make sure like
that would be the deciding factor for
you he
100 cares about his constituents and his
own well-being enough that he would care
for the well-being of those who voted
for him and those he represents
from a state that he doesn't actually
live in can you imagine what kind of
[ __ ] psycho you have to be oh yeah
and when someone walks in your house the
first time you meet them their first
impression is you pulling the trigger on
a gun right putting it together
to the head you want to play you want to
play like what the [ __ ] is he like they
they come in it becomes a negotiation
the guy's like hey listen i want to
donate a hundred thousand he's like oh
yeah
and then he's like oh what are you doing
with that gun he's like he's like are
you sure you want to do a hundred
thousand he's like okay fine fine uh 150
he goes
and then the guy also thinking he's
gonna put the gun on him he goes 150 you
think 150 is enough i'm gonna need more
than that and he's like oh [ __ ] okay
fine 250 250. he's like 250 really and
he oh god oh okay fine i'll give you
500. i'll give you 500. like that's
crazy
the dude
has someone who maybe he knows or
doesn't know and is like yeah you want
to donate the way that i'm going to help
you feel confident in giving me money is
to put a gun to my head
and let you witness possibly me
committing
my brains out
oh my god now this last one is the
number one uh fumble here is walker on
women this this herschel walker moment
on women should be just my chef kiss
spectacular let's let's listen saying
that he was accountable for past violent
behavior toward his ex-wife he had begun
to my temple
and said
it seems to be a theme he's going to
blow my brains out this seems to be like
a pattern with this guy i'm just saying
are you saying a gun is a temple
right holding guns to heads and
threatening to kill or kill yours this
seems
this seems like a very o.j simpson type
theme here which makes sense he's like
if i were to do it how would i do it
right right he's like if i were to do it
i put a gun to her temple right right
and
say i'm in control i mean he was
probably just showing her that he loved
her right right i mean he was just
trying his explanation man
let's i'm sure he's got an explanation
for this and it's probably a good
one a girlfriend said walker allegedly
threatened to blow her head off during a
dispute
this is the guy the republican party
throwing their full weight behind still
work for republicans until voters start
punishing them for putting forward these
clown candidates republican party need
to wake up
[Music]
so
so the republican party gets needs to
get woke
well that well the wokeness is the
workers are the problems
brokers are the problem
workers are the problem don't you know
this i know but i want to know they keep
telling the republican party's got to
wake up they got to wake up they got to
wake up are they in a coma
i need to know is the republican party
in a coma because i feel like they are
they're kind of on cruise control
with a lot of their policies and their
law making
and they're like you know
finger is still on the trigger but
they're
they seem to be not all the way with it
so then you got these candidates who
keep saying you got to wake up you got
to wake up and it's like so you got to
get woke is that yours everything you're
trying to wake up you're trying to go
woke
mother wokers i i tell you it's
crazy stuff but speaking of um people
cosplaying with guns and is obsessed
with guns um i don't want to switch
gears here but you did another um what
was that on um
on the uvaldi shooting yes but i want to
play you a video real quick here of a
parent from uvalde
um and she kind of explains to cbs news
here what happened
um there is definitely something going
on with you you've already police oh
yeah and what happened or what didn't
happen i'm not sure what they're trying
to cover up but man it this parent's
interview gives me more cause for
concern that there was more stuff that
they were trying to cover
let's watch arrest you because you're
being very uncooperative i said well
you're gonna have to arrest me because
i'm going in there and i'm telling you
right now i don't see none of y'all in
there y'all are standing with snipers
and y'all are far away i'm if y'all
don't go in there i'm going in there he
immediately put me in cubs she says
after ivaldi police officers told
marshalls to uncuff gomez she ran
towards the school as soon as they
uncuffed me i jumped that first gate
fence and once i jumped it i went to my
son's class
and i knocked on the door and i remember
the teacher saying um i'm like hey
they're already they're already uh boats
cutting the fence to get me she's like
you think we have time to get out he
said you have time i'm gonna run for my
other son once she was assured her son
was okay gomez ran to get her other
child encountering more officers who
tried to stop her so i start yelling and
i'm being a cooperative and i'm like
well y'all aren't doing what are y'all
doing
y'all need to be in here give me your
best somebody give me a bed some
something i started paying attention to
how far the shots were being so that i
knew the shooter was all the way still
by my first son's class so when i went
to my set my second friend's door the
teacher didn't want to open the door for
me so that's when they started um
escorting me out and as
i see that they're opening my son's door
i go run for my son and i get him with
both of her kids out safe gomez still
can't shake the thought of those who
didn't make it while you were inside the
school did you see
officers there inside this officer
inside the school when i ran
class there was not one officer and you
were hearing gunshots so you knew you
could hear that there was an active she
was still active the gunshots were still
active they were not in there there was
no one in there if anything when i
pulled up my car was closer to the
school than that than where the snipers
and everybody that was laying on the
ground were
when you heard that it took law
enforcement 75 minutes before they went
in and stopped the shooter what was your
thinking having been inside the school
yourself
i don't know i was just thinking that
they could have saved many more lives he
could have gone into that classroom and
maybe
two or three would have been gone but
they could have saved their home
oh homework the whole class they could
have done something gone through the
windows sniped them through the window i
mean
something but nothing was being done if
anything they were being more aggressive
on us parents that were willing to go in
there and like i told one of the
officers i don't need you to protect me
get away from me i don't need your
protection if anything i need you to go
in there with me to go protect my kids
and if anything they were being more
aggressive on us they're more pertain on
keeping us back than getting into that
school
so it really it seems kind of fishy here
because i think the thing that the thing
that she says that sticks with me the
most is there was not a police officer
in the school the second time she went
in for her second child and she could
still hear the gunfire um across the
school now i'm not sure you know they've
kind of shown some diagrams on how this
um
the story has changed
over 12 times now i think is what the i
mean the number is probably more than
that but like
i mean it's so much that they have said
we're no longer going to cooperate
with those who are investigating the
police the police the yuvaldi police and
the ivaldi uh school district police
right that the the the police force that
is uh inside the school the ones who
were trained
in august of 2020 for any exact event
like this
are the ones who are now saying
we're not gonna
we're not gonna participate in any way
any way shape or form
you guys didn't wanna listen to our
story change well guess what we're not
gonna help you get the answers
so well i
it's an interesting approach uh for sure
so you know i'm really hoping that the
doj coming in there and and
investigating because it's like every
day something's like more and more fishy
where you're like
this doesn't add up why did you guys not
do anything and why are you changing the
story so many times like
you know
there is video and interviews and
documents that
are clearly
logging all of the ways in which you're
changing the story now right well and
the other thing too is
there was originally reporting from
police officers on the ground reporters
were interviewing them and they said the
police officers were going in to get
their own kids um and then they kind of
backed off that there was there was talk
about he was barricaded he wasn't
barricaded was he locked in did they
lock him in did he lock himself in right
like they went back and forth on that
actual narrative i mean there's been so
many things that they've changed their
story on that you now you now don't know
the story but we know we know what
republicans want to do and 44 percent of
republicans are saying well these
shootings are just inevitable let's just
make sure we ban that back doors and
turn our schools into prisons
and you actually gave us the second
installment or what was that and it's on
this very topic so let's take a listen
just three days after the uvalde school
shooting trump headlined the nra's
national convention in houston and how
did he honor the victims
by awkwardly dancing on their graves
[Music]
okay before i start this segment here is
a list of items that i have officially
banned from my set just kidding those
were the items that were banned at the
anna race convention i can't believe i'm
saying this but they banned selfie
sticks okay who came up with this list
this is almost as ridiculous as jd vance
trying to ban porn or ted cruz trying to
ban dildos it's like
it's
wait
what if ted cruz did come up with this
list i mean dildos are technically
selfie sticks and it wouldn't be a trump
speech without him insulting others this
time he targeted abbott cornyn and
crenshaw after they decided not to
attend the nra convention and unlike
some i didn't disappoint you by not
showing up
when i first saw trump's speech i was
disgusted that he would even dare say
the names of the evaldi victims
but that quickly turned to shock mainly
because
well
i didn't know trump could actually read
here see for yourself
oops wrong video anyway this is the same
guy who said thailand yosemite in the
1775 revolutionary army took over
airports found glory across the waters
of the delaware and seized victory from
cornwallis of yorktown it took over the
airports it did everything it had to do
and in case you were wondering planes
were not used in warfare until the early
1900s
let alone airports okay here is trump
reading the victims names alexandria
rubio
[Music]
alitha
ramirez
this whole thing feels like a scene from
a dystopian film you know the one where
the villain publicly reads the names of
his victims in the town square as a
warning
very dark stuff and during a speech
trump called for a series of measures to
prevent future mass shootings finally
harden our schools and protect our
children pardon schools
why does that sound so familiar
oh right it's because republicans have
been saying the same thing since the
parkland shooting in 2018. we have to
harden our schools not soften them up
most important thing we can do is harden
these schools harden the school
hardening schools hardened sites we have
to have hardened sites god help us
if we don't harden our schools and
protect our kids the thing is uvalde did
harden its schools in august 2020 law
enforcement officers from five agencies
converged inside the hallways of a
school in uvalde texas their guns drawn
role-playing how they would halt a
gunman uvalde school officials were
doubling their budget for security
updating protocols and adding officers
to the district's police department and
despite the overhaul of security and
uvalde and across much of texas as well
as other states it has not stopped
school mass shootings in fact according
to a 2019 study there is no evidence
that hardening schools to make kids
safer from gun violence actually works
all right let's see what else trump has
to say every building should have a
single
point of entry there should be strong
exterior fencing metal detectors and the
use of new technology to make sure that
no unauthorized individual can ever
enter the school with a weapon
wait what was that single
point of entry there should be strong
exterior fencing metal detectors and the
use of new technology okay so let me get
this straight trump wants a single point
of entry strong exterior fencing a metal
detector and technology to prevent
anyone with a weapon trying to enter
he just described a prison but i guess
that shouldn't come as a surprise
considering that the private prison
industry benefited from trump
administration policies to expand
detention centers and increase profits
especially those who donated to trump's
campaign well i can't wait to hear what
else trump is pushing
that's why as part of a comprehensive
school safety plan it's time to finally
allow highly trained teachers to safely
and discreetly concealed
carry wait hold on i thought republicans
said teachers were just liberal hacks
grooming children but now republicans
are totally okay with giving teachers
guns to protect children teachers are
some of the most stressed underpaid and
under-appreciated workforces out there
they should be teaching not acting as
security guards i mean does anyone else
hear how insane this sounds i'm sorry
but i feel like i'm taking crazy pills
oh okay
before i go i just want to call
attention to another pathetic excuse for
a human being who's also on the nra
payroll texas senator ted cruz looking
at broken families absent fathers
declining church attendance social media
bullying violent online content
desensitizing the act of murder in video
games chronic isolation need i remind
you ted cruz is the guy who flew to
cancun and abandoned texas while they
froze to death not to mention when he
got caught he blamed it all on his
daughters so
i don't think he's the best person to
listen to about anything by elites i
refer to some of the most powerful
politicians and their allies in the
media many of these same people make
their accusations from behind great
bulwarks of safety from gated
communities equipped with private
security or at the very least from safe
and expensive neighborhoods protected by
high home prices and low crime rates
such people can afford an indulgent
ideology that ignores reality ted cruz
is calling other people elite okay that
is rich because if you looked up elite
in the dictionary you would see ted
cruz's face he's a princeton and harvard
law graduate who lives in a
multi-million dollar home in a very
wealthy community with private security
at this point i think we've had enough
of crews so let's just go outside and
get some fresh air
whoa were those people protesting the
nra convention well now i'm curious to
know how many people were in attendance
inside the convention oh that is
embarrassing maybe instead of banning
selfie sticks they should have just
banned smartphones because then at least
no one would know they had an awful
turnout well i'm gabe sanchez and this
has been what was that
[Music]
gabe gabe thanks for following that
report with us on what was that
stick around everyone we will be right
back with more tweety tweets and trendy
trends right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
dears tammy by the time we reach dc we
was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
yours
bomb
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the tony
michaels podcast
[Music]
gabe
the people's convoy blamed their sammich
scam
on antifa the extremist
of antifa it seems like
it seems like the former guy the cheeto
dust mobster donald trump i think antipa
is trending let's bring it up here
is trending at number 26.
um i think the reason why it's trending
is because donald trump is blaming now
we we watched the video appear peter
navarro whining and bitching about being
arrested for committing crimes that he's
indicted on
um it seems like donald trump is blaming
get this
he's blaming antifa
um
for peter navarro's arrest apparently of
course of course because you know what
it makes total sense
i i i i don't know
i i don't know if he's did he release a
statement and that's what's going on
well i don't think they release
statements on twitter anymore according
to liz harrington so you'd have to go to
uh oh you'd have to go to true social
yeah you got a truce do you have a true
social account i do but here they they
now made uh
the desktop or the the web
website version available so let me just
go oh so you can actually see you can
actually pull up
yeah um let's go to liz harrington
really quick i'll pull up her thing
because i can get the link because she
even said she's like i'm done with
twitter okay here's here i'm i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna pull i'll read this
statement if i if i can
if it's possible to read it because he
wrote it okay yeah yeah um number one 14
hours ago he wrote this
or he he [ __ ] this on true so i'm not
sure what you do over on on true social
he said now this is the first part is in
all caps truth is hot
twitter
is not that that's that's what he
he said ladies and gentlemen we have a
21st century poet on our hands
is the shakespeare of tweets
truth is hot
twitter
is not with an exclamation point and not
is cat in all caps gabe he does properly
use the trump all caps it is honestly
oh man it's like roses are red violets
are blue
true social is hot and twitter is not
he's such a [ __ ] bonehead okay here's
here's his statement
on the rest of peter navarro
our great trade genius
professor peter navarro okay already you
know this first i mean they love to push
the though he's gonna do the professor
oh my god okay let's keep going was just
handcuffed
shackled and put in jail
while the low lifes of antifa and blm
of course you can't you cannot say
antifa and you definitely cannot type it
out especially on true social it
probably will not allow you to to type
it without and blm
you have to it has to be the low-life
radical socialist commie antifa
which is anti-fascist by the way which
makes them pro fascist and black people
you gotta throw those in that right too
and tiva and blm are allowed to rip off
the public
roam free on the streets kill people and
destroy
our once great cities
all run by democrats
when will this end the american people
will not stand for it much longer
great patriotic heroes are being created
every day
what does that mean great patriotic
heroes are being created
every is there like a [ __ ] maga
factory somewhere yeah yeah you know
what it's called it's called the forced
forced births it is the republicans they
are forcing children to be born and
they're like patriots are being born
every day with ar 15 in their hand but
this sounds more like someone has told
trump or he's read somewhere on like a
facebook feed that there's a factory
that is producing
robots right and some of them are antifa
some of them are maga right they're like
humanoid robot type things like clones
and he's like great patriotic heroes are
being created there like we're making
them every day pumping them out 200 at a
time yeah every single day they come out
with a red factory they are home made
american
created america first with the trump
flag as a cape the chinese i think
they've got they've got a tattoo
probably it says american patriot with
the flag on there you know
right it may be here's here's the last
here's the last sentence if you want to
call it a sentence um in all caps
fairness and justice
must rule the day
i
so he is he's saying that the reason why
peter navarro is arrested is because
we are allowing antifa and black lives
matter to kill people
uh roam free on our streets rip off the
public yeah and this must be the
sandwich thing that he's mad yeah
they were patriots they were egypt
movement the great the great sammich
scam of 2022.
i don't i i don't know there's got to be
a parody video in there somewhere there
probably is no no i'm just gonna write
this down but i uh that's the great
sammich scam
of 2022. i'm trying to see if there's
any other word here on um if he
if he actually said something it just
seems like he he just
typed this out on true social maybe it
should be called a scammage a scam hey
there you go damage of 20 great scammage
that is great
that is great maybe we can even do uh uh
a commercial
of um
antifa antifa salmon shop or something
yeah i don't know i mean that could be
something i already have antifa airlines
right so scam way we call it scamway hey
guys
come on down to scamway where we offer
only 100 foot long sandwiches you should
see the oven [ __ ] you should see the
oven where we cook the bread it's a big
[ __ ] oven it's just a bunch of
people breathing on it
we don't even have an oven we don't even
have an oven it's just people
just just corralling around
the breast damage
shop the scammet shop yeah
oh are they [ __ ] is he [ __ ] serious
he really does say ripping people off he
definitely means the [ __ ] sandwich
thing there's no way he doesn't mean
yeah no no or i mean also again it's
projection it's a complete confession
of gripping off
who give him money he probably he
probably is the one who scammed him with
this yeah
he probably hears a story he's like oh
blah blah blah
like he's like every other word he picks
up and then he goes oh yeah antifa blah
blah blah people are saying blah blah
blah you are scamming people with your
donations and then he goes oh my god did
you hear what they're saying out there
many people have said antifa is scamming
people when it turns out it's actually
him he's the one scamming people
the great scammage of 2022. it's
fantastic some other things that we have
trending is uh the trump coup attempt
which we all know that's the cheeto dusk
kangaroo and it's ongoing
and that's also trending in politics amy
coney barrett did you see that she's
actually um in a cult uh people of
praise is what it's called i guess it's
some kind of christian handmaid's tale
type [ __ ] did you know the handmaid's
tale the seas i've never watched it but
i guess the new season season's coming
out i guess that's appropriate maybe amy
coney barrett is getting some uh
likeness rights i mean here's the thing
i made a video when she was uh
when she gave her her you know that when
they had that super smart event where
she gave me a little like oh
chris christie almost died over there
right and yeah yeah yeah yeah and a lot
of people got it you know missed
opportunities
it was a new piece of [ __ ] death it was
also who else uh uh kellyanne conway got
it from that event as well right right
uh but yeah several people did
um
it
it was a video that was about her kind
of acceptance speech like as as someone
who was getting the nomination so they
did the event and in there i did it with
my writing partner dan and he he played
coney barrett and i played the white
house pr guy and in there he's got a
binder that says that basically is the
handmaid's tale logo and it says uh um
uh
i forget what which catchphrase we went
with but basically he starts speaking
some crazy like satanic
uh
tongues and stuff and
it's uh oh surely shirley and the people
praise gold they don't speak and i'm
sure they do i mean i'm sure they do
i'll find it i'll find it right well you
know you've seen the uh the mooney cult
with the bullets
spoke at right right
were they where they worship
the ak-47s and the ar-15s it's [ __ ]
weird you talk about some [ __ ] gun
boners holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean no pun intended um
have you seen this story the defense
production act so
the right wing is losing their mind
because joe biden is using the defense
production act to wave tariffs on solar
plant panels
to bring them into the country to try to
increase the amount of manufacturing of
solar energy that we're doing in the
country um and they're they're like oh
he's using
the defense production act in the wrong
way
and he's making sure we have more energy
which is what we [ __ ] about constantly
like you [ __ ] idiots either either
blame joe biden for your quote-unquote
manufactured energy crisis or don't
and if when he does something about it
stop your bitching what the [ __ ] are you
bitching about he literally he literally
is
is waving tariffs
to make sure that those say so we can
receive more solar panels at a quicker
rate to make sure we keep up our
production of solar energy so we don't
have to i don't know burn things like
fossil fuel right you [ __ ] idiots
that you're bitching about that we're
not we're not pumping enough fossil fuel
we're not it just it it never ends with
these [ __ ] boneheads yeah like what
are you talking about now
regardless
of rather this is the correct use of the
defense production act the actual
argument that our independence on energy
is not has nothing to do with our
defense because that's the thing they're
doing is they're taking the words
defense production act right right and
they're you know they do this [ __ ]
word [ __ ] well yeah
you know but but they say it's not for
defense what is energy independence in
if it's not your national defense that's
the argument you guys make all the time
yeah constantly saying that joe biden is
should be impeached because he's not
allowing oil companies to get murph more
permits because it's against our
national defense and here he is using
the defense production act to produce
more energy yeah you [ __ ] idiots are
boneheads it is just it never ends with
these [ __ ] yeah you cannot i
mean well that's the whole strategy
right you got to make joe biden look bad
so that when the midterms come around he
can people can say well look under his
guidance this party has done nothing
and then you say on 2024 look joe biden
has done nothing because we were
unwilling to move at all
to actually help out americans but if
you guys elect us
then we will move right it's the same
way they voted against baby form it's
the same way they voted against
making sure that that corporations
oil corporations are not gouging on gas
prices they voted against it they are
voting to make sure that joe biden fails
so they can blame it on joe biden that
way they can do the same thing he's
doing i guess because you're not doing
anything different and i mean
right now we've got this issue with mass
shootings and they want to say it's gun
or they want to say it's the doors they
want to say it's the nurses they want to
see everything whatever it is
and they say okay fine let's we have
this build domestic terrorism bill and
they go yeah
no no no no
i can't do that we don't want we don't
want to make sure that you know they
blame it on mental illness and craziness
but they're like we don't want to make
sure that minimally young people yeah we
don't actually give you resources
we want to make sure we take away their
background check we want to give them
guts you [ __ ] i mean everyone sales for
the manufacturer what are you crazy well
their idea is that instead of actually
giving resources in facilities and
funding to actually help the people who
might be mentally ill they say we're
just going to lock them up we're going
to lock them up and institutionalize
them is the exact words that they use
especially trump during that nra speech
he goes we got to make it harder we got
to harden these schools and we got to
lock these people up so they can't get
guns but except you made it easy
right you're doing the exact opposite of
that you're making schools softer
because really honestly this whole
active shooter drill training if you
think about it in reality you're
training the shooters
yeah if you if you think about it in
reality you're training
you're telling them exactly what the
protocols are what they're going to do
how they're going to do it how they're
going to react to it to you coming the
school and shooting i mean they're
training i actually think that we should
actually do away with all that stuff
because you're actually creating a
situation where it's more dangerous for
those children and teachers and i mean
it's our
these
the protocol that you have to follow in
the classroom reminds me
of the same
under your desk
drills you could go on your desk if
there's a tornado go in your desk if
there's a nuclear bomb right yeah well
yeah well i mean gabe don't you know
that desks are
impenetrable it's like covered in lead
and [ __ ] yeah it's crazy [ __ ] amazing
but totally protects you just makes a
bubble totally protects you speaking of
more horseshit uh here's the uh here's
the video you made about the pile of
horseshit that is amy coney barrett
right um this is this is from a while
back this is from 2020. right but it's
this is what yeah this is one relevant
here that's when they forced her through
mitch mcconnell was like what are you
talking about we didn't force anyone
through right we didn't we don't force
anything on anyone we're not we're not
molesty rapey type gop kid littlers at
all but but you predict in this video
kind of that she's part of a
sort of a i don't know a cult so let's
let's watch please amy say a few words
here we go at least this one's a judge
so she definitely knows how to speak in
front of people thank you president
trump for this wonderful opportunity and
much like rbg i plan to use this
platform to bring this country together
i guess trump didn't know what he was
doing i thought he didn't want to go
with lego because she wasn't white but
this seems like a great choice i know
this country is ready to open his heart
to the kingdom of god a little overly
religious but that's not a problem isn't
it just so wonderful to say kingdom of
god the kingdom of galilee
please amy say a few words it seems like
that is actually what happens yep yep
don't be surprised i wanted to make a
documentary about amy coney barrett that
real life footage
is used is going to come it's going to
come about oh my god
whoo well um
i i hate to
end on that note but that we're gonna
have to we're gonna have to um
what is going on here no i don't i want
to i want to send that tweet there we go
okay
sorry i was trying to send a tweet i was
trying to send the the uh thank you
together oh yeah you weren't gonna tell
me this tweet [ __ ] sucks well i mean
i should i should every once in a while
i'll tell you your [ __ ] tweets suck
just out of nowhere not even on the show
just out of nowhere that you're dreaming
totally
so um i want to i want to talk a little
bit about these the hearings gabe so
you're putting together some graphics
yeah um for the scheduling we we're
we're starting to actually see the
schedule being more concrete here as we
get closer but it does seem like this
thursday is the very first hearing we're
gonna broadcast from the midas touch
youtube channel um we're going to be
carrying it from 7 p.m eastern which is
an hour before the hearing starts we're
going to live stream we're going to have
commentary from the legal af analyst uh
michael pobach karen and nicolo ben
mizells we're also going to have the
midas touch uh podcast guys so ben now
jordy and brett are gonna join us i
think a few others are gonna join us um
during these hearings i'm not sure
exactly who's gonna be here on thursday
but we're gonna be um broadcasting all
these select hearings but i do want to
tell everyone there's two prime time
ones so those will be special edition
um hearings where we will broadcast
those outside the podcast now there's
also going to be four other hearings and
those appear to be during our actual
broadcast yeah so what we'll do is we'll
still air those hearings and we'll still
do the podcast at the normal time
because we'll be live streaming at that
time
so so i just want to let the audience
know out there too you pay attention to
these dates look at the schedule we're
going to put out some graphics there's
also going to be a link this afternoon
that i think we're going to be able to
get to and um spread that around the
internet like herpes so that way you
guys know exactly exactly where that
link is
yeah you know that's how it works once i
mean once you get it they say go viral
they say go
yeah i'm just saying once you got it
it's with you for life so you're right
just saying we're just you know we're
we're not so much we're not like that
bad of an itch you know right well if
you put something on the internet it
lasts forever yeah spread it around like
herpes i'm not lying here i'm not no i
don't know i get it i get it i'm trying
to be you know but the
put the lotion on the skin as well right
right well
some some might some might but we are
going to broadcast every single one of
these hearings we also uh this weekend
on the 11th is the march of our lives
um they're gonna have rallies in
washington dc
uh david hogg's organization and he's
been trending he's in the news with
marjorie taylor green there and quite a
spat back and forth you know they kind
of have a history of her acting really
stupid and really stocky she's kind of a
stalker she's a david hogg stalker yeah
she harassed really gross she harassed
him there's video footage
and then she wants to say that
the people coming to dc are the ones
that are harassing which i think is
hilarious because she was harassing i
think he was 17 at the time or 16.
i mean definitely underage so you're
harassing a minor right and now she has
the uh
the goal
to come out and say oh i hear you're
coming to d.c to take away the right set
it up she's a weirdo she's a weirdo and
i wouldn't be surprised if these march
for our lives antifa extremists have
hundred foot subway sandwiches all over
the streets yes the the scammage of 2022
will not stop it will continue on june
11. so we will stream we will stream on
june 11th um i'm not sure exactly what
the schedule is for that so but i'm
hoping that we'll get at least an hour
or two of streaming some of those
speeches um where you guys can listen
and we'll give commentary and we'll try
to look at some live tweeting as that's
happening and we'll try to you know keep
you keep you entertained uh while you
watch that stuff instead of just
watching it so catch that on on june
11th we'll be releasing some graphics
and some tweets so follow us be sure to
follow us on twitter now and that's
super important at toni michael's pod
you can follow me at the tony michaels
and gabe i am gabe sanchez you can also
go sub
go subscribe
look at that yeah do you like that
i actually made that hey i actually i
made that folks that is a graphic i made
that is a graphic i made
go subscribe to the youtube channel
you're not going to want to miss a thing
over there and also gabe on these
hearings i think what we're going to do
because we can't i don't know if we'll
be able to post the entire
um bonus episodes of some of these
hearings right on on the directories but
we'll try to post some of them yeah um
as bonus episodes so you'll get your
regular two-hour episode and then you'll
get some bonus coverage of the january 6
select hearings on apple spotify and
google so make sure you go subscribe
wherever you get your podcast on your
directories go subscribe over there now
make sure you don't miss
the audio version because now that we're
in 1080p
uh you might not want to look at my my
1080p style face but if you want to hear
my beautiful voice you can go over to
the directories and you can get the
audio version if you have anything more
to wrap up before we um get out of here
i don't know
it's gonna be anything about the hearing
it's gonna be an exciting week uh yeah
it's gonna be a busy month it's gonna be
a really good june june will be crazy
busy so uh hold on to your butts and
strap in yeah and spread it around that
link the link yeah the link it is spread
the link
right make the link go viral not
anything else but you know spread it
around like
herpes
until tomorrow because we are on every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch and we simulcast
from the midas touch facebook page until
then
surfs up [ __ ]
you listening to the tony michaels
podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking